this burnt up car became a wake-up call
for the United States this was further
record neaten for my grandchildren Bert
shot up three women and six children
American citizens killed in neighboring
Mexico President Trump said in response
that cartels would be considered
terrorist organizations but it was
american-made bullets found at the scene
unlikely American make guns smuggled
across the border that he used to kill
not just this family but tens of
thousands more in Mexico
Daquan has suffered more than most this
year there's been an average of six
murders a day residents say the city's
swimming with u.s. firearms anyone can
carry a gun now and I've known cases
where they exchanged a couple of words
with someone in a taco stand and a
petrol station and they kill them
Yvonne's husband himself was shot dead
leaving her to bring up four year-old
Michelle and ten year old Danny alone
it's affected us in every way
economically as well I'm not with my
daughters we're distanced because I have
to work every day and leave them here
alone he was the breadwinner in Mexico
it's extremely hard to buy a gun legally
but criminals have found an easier way
about 70% of the firearms seized here in
traced have come from the US the state
attorney responsible for Tijuana told Al
Jazeera the Mexican cartels which have
long relied on straw buyers and now
using different tactics to buy more
weapons states are fair enthis but in
different parts of the United States
they legally buy parts of guns then they
cross them into Mexico and put the gun
together here anyone can go to a gun
store in the US and buy a gun part
there's no control of that no registry
then we find those arms at a crime scene
in Mexico and we have no way to trace
them why because they have no serial
number
once the guns or parts of guns are
bought it's easy to get them across a
porous border where there are a few
checks on the passing cars what impact
would it have on the homicide rate here
in Tijuana if suddenly it became a lot
more difficult to get guns over the
border from the US to make
man yo Crocker's hit to be around impact
I believe that it would have an
important impact the moment that the
criminals don't have a way to get
firearms will be harder to come in a
murder so of course a restriction would
have an impact in the end though the
blame lies not with the weapons but
those wielding them says a man who would
know I think it's one's own
responsibility because if they gave you
an order you have to obey if you're
carrying or not they tell me you're
going to kill those people I have to do
it and that's my own responsibility were
the ones I kill depending on what they
did wrong there are tens of thousands
though who have done nothing but have
had their families ripped apart
now all LaVon wants is a safer future
there's so much killing so many dead too
many cases unsolved people disappeared
if all of this really stopped the
traffic to Barmes the drugs we'd have a
bit of peace stopping the flow of guns
into Mexico wouldn't rectify that alone
but from politicians to experts to
ordinary Mexicans few doubt that it
would help John Holman al Jazeera
Tijuana